[Music]
my wish
is for you to help a strong sustainable
movement
to educate every child
[Music]
about food
to inspire families to cook again
and to empower people everywhere
to fight obesity
i came here
to start a food revolution that i
profoundly believe in
they had a big idea to change the world
but they couldn't do it alone
so my wish by my wish i wish
my wish and now here's my wish
[Music]
food is simple it's just raw ingredients
but it's the most powerful killer on the
planet
every child has the human right to be
taught about food where it comes from
how it affects their body and they
should be shown at school because it's
at the front line of the fight against
obesity
what happens at charles manor is that
incredible head teacher took it to the
next level
[Music]
in the past the children weren't eating
the right things i'd been inspired by
jamie to educate the school about the
fact that we're feeding the children the
wrong food
and i thought well the timetable was an
already crowded place there is so many
lessons in the primary curriculum how
can you introduce
another subject for teachers to teach
so we looked at english we looked at
maths science history geography and we
saw how we could put that around food
when you incorporate cooking it's
something everyone looks forward to
today we're doing a little bit of
science in the kitchen we are going to
combine our lessons on diwali but also
our lessons on shape and symmetry would
you say this is a physical change or a
chemical change that i'm making
physical change you're all right for
history topics we talk about the whole
history of chocolate and so we can do a
whole topic around that okay and the
aztecs have been cooking with chocolate
and mostly and it's interesting because
it's not made as they think with all the
milk in that they would have had and the
taste
is very very different
some children like it some children
don't
for maths simple weighing and measuring
we're going to be doing a lot of
measuring because we have to measure out
some liquids which we did last term we
did some measuring
what he's done is he's put food at the
heart of the school and he's fed the
stomach and the mind
chuckle manor is a state school about 80
of children come from areas that are
identified as in poverty
the children had very little experience
of being outside in the countryside
knowing about food growing
over a period of time we were able to
build the garden
welcome to the secret garden this is our
greenhouse this is our compost bin this
is our armory
[Music]
this is our vegetable patch
and these are our
chickens the chickens come out and they
try and chase you
i had to run for my
[Music]
life at the community garden we've got
two polytunnels so we can grow all year
round
[Music]
i will pick
onions broccoli
and carrots because they're all healthy
they make you stronger
obviously and they just make me happy
so yeah
[Music]
12 or 13 years ago there was a
reluctance to engage in this sort of
curriculum there were many people that
couldn't see what we were aiming for and
what we were trying to do obesity hadn't
reached the
epidemic proportions it has reached now
we gain children that look and appear
more healthy concentration is so much
higher behavior issues are incredibly
lower than they have been in the past
one of the great things they've done is
introduced us to worlds of healthy food
before i was a really picky eater i feel
better when i eat healthier food
[Music]
you fail your mouth's a level that's not
going to shorten your life by 10 years
you don't die young because you didn't
do your geography homework these kids
die young if they don't know how to feed
himself i think tim
and the team would inspire head teachers
across the world and parents
any teacher has the same capacity to be
as brilliant as he is his story we want
to replicate but the truth is we've got
so much
more to do
jamie really revolutionized our school
dinners and it really has
hugely impacted on all the children but
so many in a deep way which is going to
stick with them for the rest of their
lives
when you change a life like that it
makes it all worthwhile from all of us
at chapel manor thank you jamie thank
you jamie
thank you jamie
[Music]
you